the failed former president Donald Trump
exploded on his platform Troth Central
after a jury found him liable for sexual
assault and defamation of e Gene Carroll
in that Bergdorf Goodman Department
Store in Manhattan in the 1990s you knew
he was going to absolutely lose his mind
let's take a look at the various
uncontrollable posts sort of like
diarrhea of the post rather than the
mouth right before the decision was made
Trump trothen quote waiting for a jury
decision on a quote on a capital f false
accusation where I despite being a
current political candidate and leading
all others in both parties am not
allowed to speak or defend myself now
that's a lie Trump could have testified
in fact he said he was flying back to
the U.S to testify his lawyers were like
no you're not dude you're not doing that
um saying even as hard-nosed reporters
scream questions about this case at me
in the meantime the other side has a
book falsely accusing me of capital r
rape and is working with the Press I
will therefore not speak until after the
trial but will appeal the capital u
unconstitutional silencing of me as a
candidate no matter the outcome now
remember while he was President Eugene
Carroll wanting to have these
allegations adjudicated wasn't fair
because Trump was a sitting president
now that Trump's no longer a president
the whole trial is unfair because he's a
candidate
endless then we got the decision and
that's when Trump turned on caps lock
and really went in for the crazy Trump
posting after the verdict quote I have
absolutely no idea who this woman is
this verdict is a disgrace a
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
of all time then trophing again in all
capital letters very unfair trial and
then the video started Trump using truth
Central almost like a short form like
Tick Tock a short form Vlog platform
posting these 15 and 20 second videos
let's take a look at the first one here
Trump putting on his suit and tie and
standing in front of flags in order to
deliver these unhinged statements if you
can imagine this was a
say this was a very unfair trial right
and there that's the that's the full
statement from Trump in that particular
video then he wrote and it's funny it
says it's a 15 second video but because
of like the the little closing uh
animation it's really only like a seven
second video Trump then posting a 21
second video I have absolutely no idea
who this woman is the verdict is a
disgrace a continuation of the greatest
Witch Hunt of all time
absolutely a shame
so that's Trump reading the truth that I
mentioned to you earlier I guess they
just put it up on the on the
teleprompter maybe that's why it's in
all caps to make it easier for Trump to
read I don't know it's all very strange
and then Trump putting out a slightly
lengthier Vlog about this what else can
you expect from a trump hating
clinton-appointed judge who went out of
his way to make sure that the result
of this trial was as negative as it
could possibly be now there's no
evidence that any of this is true every
lawyer I spoke to this morning said that
the judge handled the case perfectly
fine speaking to and in control of a
jury from an anti-trump area which is
probably the worst place in the United
States for me to get a fair trial
we'll be appealing this decision it's a
disgrace I don't even know who this
woman is I have no idea who she is where
she came from this is another scam I'm
finding this a little difficult to
believe to be perfectly honest with you
it's a political Witch Hunt and somehow
we're gonna have to fight this stuff we
cannot let our country go into this
Abyss this is disgraceful you have
somebody running for office you have a
woman that's financed and lied about it
she totally lied about it by Democrat
operatives like just about the biggest
one there is
and she said that wasn't true they found
that she lied about it isn't this
incredibly whiny and the judge wasn't
even I guess letting it be put in as
evidence huh the whole thing is a scam
and it's a shame and it's a disgrace to
our country there you go
very powerful statement from Donald
Trump so listen um we've got Trump who
has now been arrested and charged in New
York found civilly liable in New York
likely to be arrested and charged again
in Georgia sometime between I'm trying
to remember the dates we heard from
Fannie Willis down in Georgia I believe
it was between July 11th and September
1st or something like that where they
they have this next charging period
where grand jury decisions will be made
and charging decisions will be made this
is not going very well for Donald Trump
but I have to hand it to the Maga people
his support among the Republican party
is only going up and so it still appears
that this is very much not good for
Trump in terms of the general election
although he still could win you look at
the polling it's close but it is it is
actually quite good for Trump in the
Republican primary and in some way it's
some indirect way
Trump's charges and the 5 million dollar
liability finding and how all of this
stuff it may be desantises undoing
because it's actually boosting Trump now
Trump has a town hall tonight on CNN
uh we're going to talk about that later
uh and they damn well damn well better
ask about this stuff but I don't I don't
know that it will we'll get to that a
little bit later when you're using
websites and apps your device sends out
data about you into the open who you are
where you go things you like that data
then gets sold around for advertising
purposes which is why every time I
connect to the internet I use a VPN to
hide my IP address and our sponsor
private internet access is the most
trustworthy VPN on the market it's the
only VPN that has proven multiple times
in court they don't log your activity
private internet access protects you
from the prying eyes of hackers your
internet service provider tech companies
private internet access is also super
fast for streaming and for downloads you
can watch your favorite streaming
platforms as if you're in another
country like the UK to access cool new
content and with just one account you
can protect unlimited devices all at the
same time this is really a game changer
private internet access is giving my
audience 83 percent off that's 203 a
month plus four months free go to Pia
vpn.com Pacman the link is down below